well it's a great pleasure to be here
and and talk to you all I have to say
I've never seen such a big audience here
it's terrific so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to give a seneschal the talk
that I I gave in Stockholm a few little
add-ons I have to say too and I'll start
with a little bit of history tour of how
I got where I am not a lot but some and
I should say that my my passion and
really is my passion for trying to
understand how macromolecules function
in biology and understanding biology at
the molecular level started from a
lecture that I heard by Max Perutz in
1963 it was a Dunham lecture at Harvard
and and he talked about his structural
studies on hemoglobin and Kendra's
studies on myoglobin now they had won
the Nobel Prize in Chemistry just the
year before for their determining these
structures and so max showed a stereo
slide of myoglobin in the auditorium
with at least as many people as here or
maybe even more and it was a very large
screen over his head and we had all had
color glasses on and he went back and
forth you know how that works and all of
a sudden it popped into three dimensions
and the audience went whoa
I don't expect that will happen here
but none of us had ever seen a molecule
of protein in three dimensions and that
was when I knew that's what I wanted to
do I want to understand biological
molecules at the atomic level in three
dimensions and that's what I've been
pursuing so then I went and worked in
Bill lips Thames lab at Harvard on the
structure of carboxypeptidase a Lipscomb
won the prize in chemistry prize in 1976
for his work on boron hydrides not
exactly
protein crystallography no no and there
I got to interact with the Watson and
group learning about ribosomes which
they were studying at the time and also
Wally Gilbert on transcription
regulation and then I went to Cambridge
to work on chymotrypsin and interacted
with with Francis Crick and it was
really my interactions with those
individuals and particularly at
Cambridge that triggered my interest in
trying to understand the simple dog
dogma of molecular biology the central
dogma as you all know is DNA is copied
into DNA by DNA polymerase is and we
have studied many DNA polymerase 'iz and
continue to do so and then the RNA is
copied into our DNA is copied into RNA
using RNA polymerase and that's
regulated we've been studying that and
then the tRNA has an amino acid attached
of by aminoacyl trna synthetases and
we've been studying that so we we went
through this of progression and then
about 1995 we got to the point that we'd
reached the stage where we needed to
look at the ribosome now when I was a
graduate student at Harvard this was a
figure that Jim Watson
for a publication and that was what was
known in 1964 about ribosome structure
and function I was known that there was
an amino acyl tyranny didn't know what
the structure was and there was decoding
by the messenger RNA and the small
subunit and there was a peptidyl trna in
the what was called the P site but it
wasn't known that there was an e site
the exit site it wasn't known that the
polypeptide went through a tunnel and
there were no molecular details at all
it was known that there was a
translocation there were a number of
good things known well the the ribosome
is a very large RNA containing machine
it's the largest RNA containing cheap
machine and in cells it has three
thousand nucleotides in the bacterial
ribosome large subunit 34 proteins and
then the smaller subunit that is about
half that size it's a 2/3 RNA by mass
and it's one quarter of the bacterial
cell mass and that's useful if you want
to do structural studies you need to be
able to make material so that was very
helpful now Jim lake started structural
studies in 1976 and this is using
electron microscopy negatively stained
and he could get the shape of the
ribosome and as you'll see that's pretty
much right this is called the crown view
for obvious reasons and then this was
the shape of the small subunit and then
they sort of snuggle up to each other
when they form the 70s and then in 1997
Yocum Frank used cryo-em methods a
single particle cryo-em methods to get
us somewhat higher resolution structure
something like 24 angstrom you see
little indentations he positioned the
tRNAs the a site P site and esight
tyrannies but not exactly accurately and
where the messenger RNA would go so
that's where it was in the mid-90s and
as I said we had gotten to the point
where we were thinking what should we do
next and out of your life had starting
in 1980 grown crystals of the ribosome
and then a got crystals of the species
that I'm gonna work on the hill Erica
Maris mortuary a large subunit but
didn't she published a paper in 1995 now
not everybody in this audience is going
to look at this and be able to decide
whether it's good bad or indifferent but
this was a seven angstrom resolution
electron density map that she thought
was moving along to understand the
ribosome structure well many of us
looked at that and realize that it
wasn't actually correctly done yet so we
wanted to get into it well the right
person at the right time came no.not
bond JAMA Eliab in 1995 and he wanted to
work on the ribosome so I said right and
then I decided we should collaborate
with Peter more I've known Peter since
we were graduate students graduate
students at Harvard and he's a longtime
ribosome expert and he likes to catch
big fish as you could see and and of
course the ribosome is a big fish and so
I thought yes he's the right person and
and then Paul Nissen came from a Denmark
a couple years after Nana blonde and he
joined in it really was bond and this
and who I think were they the core of
solving the structure so then you might
ask well what was the problem why was
this heart
well the ribosomes big but soul and what
does that mean whoops so we were able to
make crystals following out of gillnitz
procedure but the crystals initially had
a lot of
problems they were very very thin they
were not well they often had fragments
they had problems and then we had to
improve that but what you can do I'm not
going to give you an x-ray course here
you will be happy to know I give us a
mystery course or a semester course if
you wish but what I want to say to you
is the problem is you you can measure
the intensities of the diffraction
pattern but you need to get something
else it's called the phase I won't go
into what that is but the way you do
that is to use a method that was
initiated by Max Perutz one of the
reasons you got the prize and that is
you bind a heavy atom to the crystal and
you collect the data again and you
locate that heavy atom never mind how
you do that and I say the problem with
the ribosome is like the problem of
trying to measure the weight of the ship
captain with and without the boat now if
you have a sailboat and a pretty good
sized ship captain you can measure these
two and measure this and then subtract
them and you can do it and that's sort
of like a lysozyme 14,000 molecular
weight and and tungsten was 78 electrons
however if you try to do that with the
Queen Mary this is a bigger challenge
because the the error would be much
larger and you can't measure the weight
of the ship captain and I think this is
like the ribosome sort of the Queen Mary
of the macromolecular assemblies and so
this is not a heavy enough atom so what
one had to do was use what are called
cluster compounds so this one tungsten
18 has 18 tungsten atoms and with the
other atoms it has 2,000 electrons
instead of 78 and we use some other
cluster comments as well and it turns
out that it this is the most detailed
crystallographic talk part of the talk
you're gonna hear I won't go press on
this for a long time but this is the
important point and this is what got us
going and the others as well
subsequently
at very low resolution not that you all
know what resolution is but a low
resolution like 20 angstroms is just
down here somewhere the scatter from
from these cluster compounds goes more
or less through the ceiling and that's
because at the scatter goes as a square
of the number of electrons and so the
signal is about 600 times larger than
the signal from just a single atom and
here this is the scatter with over a
hundred osman hexa means so this is a
very so what we did is we took very low
resolution data we got the signal we
measured the weight of the ship captain
in spite of the fact it was the Queen
Mary I located the heavy atom and then
started solving the structure and and
this is where Jakob Frank was with using
cryo am I always say this is like a
Moore statue not Peter Moore Henry Moore
with he's holding a torch and there's
his head and there's his arms and he's
kneeling down here so it was very hard
to make an atomic interpretation of this
so so our first publication was in 1998
in which we had a nine angstrom
resolution math very low resolution but
we could see the twists and turns of the
irony so we knew we were on the right
path and besides it looked the shape was
the same as the twenty angstrom
resolution of reconstruction and then
the next year we got to 5 angstrom
resolution and in fact auto unit and
Venki Ramakrishnan followed the same
route and they got there too as as well
as Harry Knoller
and then at 2000 we got to 2.4 angstrom
resolution and you can't see certainly
not in this room the detail here but we
could actually position every single
atom it took us several months to do
that but we were able to do that and so
here is the structure that we got or a
representation of the structure that we
got
mm mm the RNA has shown with a red
backboned sugar phosphate backbone and
the white bases a very tightly packed
RNA so we had no idea what irony was
going to look like in this large
assembly not a clue
proteins are in blue embedded around the
surface again the contrast isn't very
large but there's where the substrate
binds and you'll notice there's not much
blue there I'll come back to that
momentarily now
oh there we go so this is okay
this is the large ribosomal subunit that
we determined to here at Yale this is a
small sieve it determined by Venki
Ramakrishnan and put together using
hairy Nola's data on the on the 70's and
here are three key Rene's borrowed as
well and we're gonna spend most of our
time down here in what's called the
peptidyl transferase center what peptide
bond formation occurs that's where the
amino acids are stuck together and then
this hole is where the messenger RNA
goes in and Venki Ramakrishnan got a lot
of information as to how in the world
the decoding goes if I just rotate this
around you can see the very complicated
shape that the RNA takes it's pretty
closely packed but there are little gaps
and the protein of the RNA has little
gaps in it the protein fits into those
into those gaps again you can see the
complicated shapes now if we split the
large subunit open like like an apple
and this is a space-filling rendition in
white is the RNA you see again it's
pretty tightly packed little little
holes here and there and the protein is
penetrating into the RNA to sort of act
a little bit of a glue to hold it
together and here's again the peptidyl
transferase center p key and this is a
model built where the polypeptides exit
would be that's about a hundred
angstroms long so that's the exit tunnel
so there are a lot of proteins I think
there are about 14 where there's a
globular domain and I'm just a sort of
winding highly charged piece of protein
and that piece of protein these pieces
of proteins sort of fit into the RNA to
sort of hold it together
and particularly I point out l2 and l3
which have these big red parts and then
if we look at where they are in a
close-up view here's where the active
site is and and an analogue subject
analog here there's the globular part
and and the non globular purchase sort
of threads in around and comes close to
the peptidyl transferase center but it
doesn't actually make it all the way now
Francis Crick who always predicted good
things I mean right things he was
amazing he he thought and 19th put out
in 1968 the following quote I'm not sure
I can do it British accent oh it is
tempting to wonder if the pivot of
ribosome could have been made in time
Lee of RNA and of course the reason for
saying this was that how could you have
a protein make the first protein because
how would you get the first protein to
make the first protein it's a chicken
and egg problem so it was a clearly a
good idea and and and really endorsed by
almost everybody through the years but
there wasn't any proof so when we looked
at what's the closest polypeptide to the
peptidyl transferase center this is what
we found in 2000 now it turns out
there's a little bit of disordered chain
here that we didn't know about at that
time but it still can't get close enough
to get to the peptidyl transferase
center so of just so you don't miss the
point the ribosome is a ribozyme that
means the catalysis is done by RNA now
of course it Altman shared the prize 20
years ago with Tom Cech for also
discovering the first of ribosomes so
okay so RNA does the Catholic catalysis
how does it do it what's the source of
the ribosomes catalytic power because
RNA wouldn't necessarily be a chemist
first choice is what he or she would use
to catalyze a reaction so how does it do
it well this work was done initially by
Jeff Hanson and then most of it by
Martin Schmidt Jeff postdoc Martin a
graduate student at their time and
here's Martin with his sailboat on our
salt marsh he had finished his degree
but I wanted to finish two papers so I
said okay you can put your boat on our
salt marsh and you know just hang out
for another six months and and and and
he did and he published a paper in
Nature and one and forget cell molecular
biology or something all right so that
was good
I find out by the way that global
warming is a problem that this picture
was taken five years ago and now the
salt marshes eroded so this rock is up
against water and my geology colleagues
tell me that that's because the ocean
levels are rising and the salt marches
are eroding very fast well anyhow back
to
back to peptide bond formation so here's
the reaction that's catalyzed I don't
it's a sort of a dark slide um of I have
to apologize there's a site tRNA that
has an amino acid on it and it's the
Alpha amino group of that amino acid
that attacks the cardinal carbon of the
pepti peptidyl trna and that's in the p
site
well we couldn't get these tRNAs into
our crystals so what we did is we used a
fragment and biochemists have been using
a fragment reaction for many years and
so one just uses CC a amino acid or CC a
and a peptide analog then this goes on
to form a what's called a tetrahedral
carbon intermediate with a- oxyanion
here and then goes to product was a
product winding up into a site and then
it has to translocate back to the P site
so what we did what we've done and I'm
not going to show you but a very small
fraction of the work on this I solved
many structures of intermediates
products and substrates to try and put
it together in a movie and I I will show
you a movie of this process that Martin
shman made which is always quite popular
so again if we take the 50s something
and split it so that you can see the
exit tunnel here the three chart tRNAs
borrowed from harry Knoller the proteins
penetrating into the interior and
there's the peptidyl transferase center
and we're going to be thinking inside
this this little box for a while and
addressing the problem how how does
peptide bond formation happen well
initially what was done was to find a cc
a to the a site with a with an amino
acid on it and it binds to what harry
nor had described early as the a loop
hydrogen bonds to one of the base for in
one base pair and the CCA with a peptide
binds to what's called the p loop a
Knoller again making two hydrogen bonds
in this case and there's the attacking
alpha amino group it has to tack this no
we looked at it we said well that
orientation doesn't look quite right but
yeah it's probably just not an accurate
structure well then I went to Sweden to
give their they're a lot of Nobel
symposium that one can get invited to
sometimes I I thought it was sort of
like a qualifying exam you know yeah
you're up there giving your talk and the
Nobel Committee sitting in the front row
I'm gonna go oh my god the students
understand that right so the question
was asked why is peptidyl trna not
hydrolyzed in the absence of the a-site
trna because if the if the structure is
all set up to go why can't water attack
the carbonyl carbon instead of the Alpha
amino group and this was the same
question that was asked by Koshland 50
years ago about hexokinase and why we
studied EXO kindness in the first place
because he asked well why isn't ATP
hydrolyzed in the absence of glucose
after all glucose is just a water
molecule with a few carbons attached and
he said ah there has to be a
conformational change and that's that's
the answer here as well and so while I
was unable to answer the question in
Sweden Marchmain was back at work in the
lab and came up with the answer by the
time I got back and so what he found was
that if you don't have the a-site
substrate bound this peptide
linked group the peptidyl group is
buried so this is where a water molecule
would have to be either here here and
they can't get there it's sterically
blocked by by the rabbits
detective so what he did is he looked at
several substrates and I'll show you a
movie this will probably a little easier
to understand but the Bajor point is
that if he has CA in the a site there's
not much of a conformational change but
if he has si si a and there are a lot of
biochemical data for y1 did this what
happens is this protecting base moves
out of the way and there's a
reorientation and as actually of the
peptide yield group and reorient so that
it's now ready for chemistry so what
happens okay here's the undo state wrong
orientation really but then when you get
the induced state this moves out of the
way and you get this in position to
attack which you can then do and you get
this tetrahedral intermediate the
oxyanion that's formed and that's what
it would be look like with a was a
substrate sidechain on so that's that's
what it looks like the ground state
where it starts and so there are two
groups that could be involved in the
chemistry of the catalysis
now all catalysis by enzymes is
activated by or
enhanced by the orientation of two
substrates it's entropy Jenks described
this nearly forty years ago so that's
the biggest effect all enzymes do that
but what else do they do well there's a
hydroxyl group here from the P site
sugar and there's a base here with a
nitrogen well initially we thought well
I wonder if it could be the base not our
best hypothesis I have to say because it
turns out to be wrong as I'll mention
and the other possibility is that this
hydroxyl has an important role and that
turns out to be right so Rachel Greene
beaut ated that particular a to all the
other all three other bases and
that was a full-length tyranny made no
difference so clearly that wasn't
important for catalysis
however Scott Strobel also working with
Rachel Greene I showed that if they
remove that hydroxyl group from the
p-site substrate the rate went down a
very large amount so clearly it was
important for something a similar
experiment but using fragments what had
been done by Barta in Austria in 2002
and she found a just a couple hundred
fold a difference but she found also
that when this hydroxyl was removed the
rate went down so she hypothesized using
our structural information and her
results
she had pasta sized that this hydroxyl
is acting as sort of a proton shuttle so
it's acting as a general base namely
picking up the proton from this
attacking of amino group and then acting
of the general acid to provide it to the
leaving three prime hydroxyl group and I
and there have been some experiments
have been done subsequently and that's
pretty well I think agreed upon as the
mechanism and what what the enzyme is
doing then another thing that enzymes do
is stabilize transition States lower the
activation barrier and is it doing that
well we used a substrate again
synthesized in Scott Strobel's lab by
Kevin Huong
and this is an analogue of the
intermediate and the carbon is mimicked
by a phosphorus and the oxygen by a
sulphur so we could see it and then
there's a mimic of a sidechain and this
is quite high-resolution considering
it's the ribosome I might say so we
could see where all the atoms are and if
we look we see that there's a water
molecule interacting with this oxy anion
mimic being held in place by the by the
RNA of the ribosome and so that could
indeed be stabilizing because there's a
quite a dipole moment
and the irony around the water brother
sorry
so what's the source of catalytic power
substrate orientation by the 23 s RNA
very important proton shuttle by the to
2 prime hydroxyl and probably transition
state stabilization well I think
everybody's ready for a movie by now
and so this movie was made by Martin SH
main music was composed by others and
what he did is he took each of the many
structures that he determined and then
morphed in between these structures so
every time there's a little R factor
down in this corner that's a real
structure and things in between might be
you know a little disney-esque okay
okay so here's the large ribosomal
subunit and there's the peptidyl
transferase center and so we're going to
land at the peptidyl transferase center
so and we'll concentrate on the peptidyl
transferase enter
and we have now the P loop and the a
loop we're just showing that and now we
have the peptidyl CCA the P site
substrates coming in making its two base
pairs and you see the carbonyl group is
protected by these two bases now we have
the attacking a site substrate and
making one hydrogen bond and this is the
undo stop chair and then now with
there's a conformational change you get
the induced structure so this gets
oriented properly there's a stabilizing
water molecule now we're ready for the
attack of the Alpha amino group the
Alpha media group
okay it seems to have worked so here's
the tetrahedral carbon with the oxy
anion interacting with a water molecule
and then it breaks down to give the
product and then the D isolated CCA or
actually tRNA in the real case goes to
the e site the exit site so now it's
this is made up of course we don't know
how it gets there exactly it's going
over to the e site and the CCA will be
interacting with the e site the a
because a 76 is going to be stacked in
here and now there's no room for an
amino acid which is why only the DA
slated tRNA gets in here and now now
there's one more trip it's a rotation of
180 degrees the P site kept until CCA it
goes our East site a site rather goes to
the P site okay so that's
that's what we know about it
so I gave a lecture once in Cambridge at
the 100th under 150 a--the anniversary
the structure of DNA and I got to this
point and I asked Richard Henderson who
was the head of the laboratory should I
continue saying I don't think you can
top that so but I'm going to continue
because I want to move on now and talk
about the practical applications of the
ribosome structure and that is it's a
major target of antibiotics and we can
understand how it works from our
structural studies and it can be
information can be using is being used
to design new antibiotics not by us but
by ryebeck pharmaceuticals as I'll get
to so as you all know resistant strains
of bacteria are a major problem this was
in the New York Times a couple years ago
but Mr sa methicillin-resistant Staph
aureus causing the number here is 19,000
tests in US hospitals alone I've seen
numbers up to 99 thousand for all
resistant strains everywhere anyhow it's
a large number of people who die from
the lack of ability for the antibiotics
to work and most of the antibiotics
sorry about half the antibiotics target
the large ribosomal subunit the one
we're studying and and and and I
actually half of them do so it's a major
major target now this work was done by
Jeff Hanson who also did some of the
substrate of work this is one of our
summer picnics one of the nice things
about living in New Haven as many of you
know as the shoreline is is gorgeous and
it's so what's really very nice so Jeff
started by binding macro lights to the
ribosomes large subunit and out
erythromycin is probably one that you
know about you've taken you don't know
what it is maybe all of you
z-pak there's my son now turns out that
you bacteria and hail are cameras more -
I is not a you bacteria but in our key
bacteria archaea bacteria are really
eukaryotes in disguise they hung out
with the eukaryotes for about a billion
years after they split off from the you
bacteria and so they're very similar and
and and so how could we bind antibiotics
to this you back are this eukaryote
look-alike well it turns I just go to
very high concentrations and with some
of them he was able to do it and so here
is where the macro light ring binds
peptide bond formation occurs up here
this is down in the tunnel and there's
there three of them here the Rings
buying more or less the same way and
they differ by what the substitutions
are that's that's how the different
antibiotics of a different one from the
other so how do they function well again
this is a split open ribosome that's the
position of the macrolide at the in
green our residues mutation make the
ribosome resistant to the antibiotic and
now if we look up the tunnel we can see
there's what peptide bond formation
occurs on the and the peptide comes out
this this tunnel but there's what
happens oh that's where the antibiotic
binds blocking the exit of the
polypeptide I call as molecular
constipation it actually I said this in
Sweden and nobody laughed I think they
understand what's there English is
really good but I don't think they
understood constipation
the word that is so we did some studies
to try and understand how these
mutations actually affect the binding of
the antibiotics now turns out that in
e.coli mutation on this a reduces the
binding constant rhythm Ison by ten
thousandfold and it turns out that in
hey larkey mares more chewy that a is a
G just as it is in eukaryotes so it
doesn't bind through a large fraction of
antibiotics called MLS K including
erythromycin so why is that well when we
looked at where that nitrogen that's on
the G but not on the egg lies it's right
under this hydrophobic rain it has to
get D solvated and what's more it
doesn't fit tightly so that we
hypothesized was the reason why this
bound much less tightly so what was done
by DA Chi 2 is a joint graduate student
between Peters lab and mine and Gregor
Blanco stock in my lab was to to mutate
the Hilmer RQ mares March away that G
into an a sort of the reverse of a
resistance mutation of non-resistance
mutation and when they did that they
found that all the of these family of
antibiotics did buying previously bound
erythromycin clindamycin Virginia mice
and just a whole bunch of them found
very well and if you look with the
rhythm Ison if there's a G here even at
3 milli molar which is saturated
concentration it didn't bind but with
the mutation point 0 0 3 which is about
the lowest we could use in the Chris
it completely saturated so we estimated
about a 10,000 fold in the binding
constant and then if we look at one
compound azithromycin that we could bind
up at very high concentrations 10
millimolar both the halo are cámaras
more chewy and to the mutated of
ribosome you see that it moves down by
about an angstrom but not much why are
you in the same place and there's where
that pesky little nitrogen is that gets
in the way of its binding so that's why
I would say the use of these structures
well I have is useful to use these
structures to design new antibiotics in
spite of Yale work at Marist mortuary
not being a you bacterial I might say
it's more important to have an accurate
structure perhaps than a youth bacterial
structure I just want to point out that
oh and a lot of you know that's work
early on of she had the antibiotic
erythromycin oriented this way and it's
actually oriented this way and we've now
looked at another you bacteria and to
see exactly the same thing so this is
the correct one now different families
of antibiotics bind nearby places I'm
not going to go through them all here's
the peptidyl transferase center peptide
bond formation here's one that binds to
what's called an a site because that's
for the a site subject binds there many
to bind here
here's varsa my son virginia my son
blastocyte and chloramphenicol which
also binds up here and the macrolide so
what do you do with this information and
here's where I'm going to transition
into what is being done by Rybak's
what you can do is you could take a
piece of one of these molecules and tie
it chemically to a piece of another one
to make a hybrid molecule and you use
that using the structure computational
methods develop initially and build
Jorgensen's lab and
chemistry department and these methods
work very well and so they're Rybak's
which is on George Street 300 George
Street has been working since 2001 when
high in several my colleagues of Peter
and Bill others founded it and they're
they're getting good results so here's
an example
never mind the chemical details here you
can't see them any island it doesn't fit
any matter so what they're doing is
they're taking a one compound Lynnae
solid which is sold by Pfizer it's a
major new antibiotic new some years old
but and combine it with sparse and my
son was basically a rat poison that is
it's not discriminating so if you look
at the selectivity lynnae's Allah does
select you bacteria but not not
eukaryotes
whereas sparse amaizing isn't and then
what what is measured by the
microbiologist is something called the
mi see it's not mi ckey is what many of
us know mo USC but though this is mi c
is the minimum inhibitory concentration
and you have to have be below for it to
be effective
and learn a slit as you can see is quite
effective in many of these cases but not
all of them and so these are the various
combinations they may just tying them
together never mind the details and they
found up for example one here it looks
pretty good point five point five 16 -
hi 128 still not good so then what you
do is you do cycles of of this and again
a whole bunch of cycles let's say 260
issue and then you look at the mi C's
against - tough strains so you see this
this was one that they didn't target
neither Dylan hazel it but there it is
it's down to two and this is very good
so they've made compounds now they call
it take out one that they call read a
slit and it will work against all kinds
of resistant bacterial strains here
zithromax z-pak doesn't work against any
of these and here's a vancomycin a
really busy man easily resistant
vancomycin resistant strain works very
well against these compounds from our
backs work very well and here and it's
not just Mrs say that's a problem there
are other kinds of resistant strains
again enterococci here's what Renee's
Allah does all fine
vancomycin terrible linezolid not good
enough so the day's loads now made it
through phase two clinical trials and so
it's looking pretty good many of us are
very enthusiastic about that the company
has several compounds that are in
preclinical trials that are looking good
getting lined up to go into the clinic
include one that was a de novo design
just starting from scratch that works
against gram-negative bacteria which is
also a major problem so I think it's
going to be very good and then I'm going
to end the science part with just one
last thing where do we go from here I
always get asked what are you gonna do
next future is hard to predict but let
me talk about tuberculosis 192 people
will die from tuberculosis during the
next hour it's a major major problem not
in this part of the world but certainly
in the third world although I think we
could get into trouble as well so what
we have done is we've bound two
compounds that are active against TB and
to 70s ribosome structure that we have
done with three tRNAs bounded and let me
just say and this is impressed
not out yet so it binds between the two
subunits there's there's the tRNA that's
in the a site now we're zooming in so
here's the tRNA it's being it's
interacting with a messenger RNA this is
what was found initially by Venki
Ramakrishnan and there are two bases
that are flipped out 1492 1493 better
stabilizing this interaction and the
what this compound bio myosin is doing
is stabilizing this whole ensemble just
gluing it right there and stopping it
now why is this important well it turns
out that here's Vaio Meissen Caprio
myosin binds in the same place and there
are two compounds that Venki found were
bound to the small subunit hi girl my
son B I'm parola my son and what's once
again one can only think well maybe the
Rybak's trick will work here and maybe
one can make new antibiotics and there's
a string called XDR that is arising in
South southern Africa a major resistance
Jenkins it's resistance again all
antibiotics no matter what the target
molecule is and the question is can that
be combated the challenge of course is
going to be to get funding for that
because this cure is pure poor people
but hopefully we can do something about
that
so I'm going to I'm going to stop there
I'm going to make some thank yous if I
if I may a few people I didn't mention
and Peter Moores group Betty freeborn
with the technician who made the
ribosomes early on and Larissa fellow
Sanka made them subsequently let's see
who else did I not mention Dan Klein I
worked on many of the structural aspects
in the later stages and I have to
mention that Scott Strobel has this lab
synthesized some of the compounds and I
should also mention my fellow chemistry
winners
yo NAT and Thank You Ramakrishnan this
is before he discovered he needed to
shave in order to get through security
he said he always was you know patted
down and had all kinds of trouble
but as soon as he shaved boom right
through so in case you think there's no
profiling you're wrong
so this was at another one of those
meetings in Sweden a few years ago a
very nice location and then I should
mention that I was able to take 14 gas
plus Joan of course with me to Sweden
and I had a number of family members but
I was also able to take Yale former
associated Yale people or present ones
Peter of course being a pivotally
important person Peter more and then
there's Nana bond and Paul Nissen Nana's
now a head of a very successful
laboratory and Zurich and Paul is very
doing very well in at the head of the
structural biology and our who's and and
there's Jeff Hanson and and Martin Shmi
and I also invited Peggy Ann Thornton to
come along because she she handles so
much of my workload but it could the
paper workload and she stabilizes the
whole lab crew making them work together
so that's very helpful so we had a good
time and I also have to mention the
environment in which all this happened
in 1995 here were the people who were in
structural biology at Yale
there was the worms group called worms
because it's Wyckoff angleman Richards
Moore and Stites
and then in the mid to late 80s HHMI
started supporting and by 1995 there was
Jennifer Doudna Paul Sigler and axel
Bruner this was a great group seven out
of the eight are or were in the National
Academy of Science
very very distinguished group and I have
to say science doesn't happen in a
vacuum
it's very important to have a good
environment within which to work and
this was a great environment and this
this is the hoo-ha that happened after
the presentation a wonderful banquet and
the server's I don't know how they did
it there were 1500 people there gorgeous
tables and and music and and lots of
singing and dancing and some of us
there's Venki
I think there's out of you on that a
little hard to see the crown princess
I'm behind the candlestick here
sitting at the main table and then
here's what was in the front page of the
Swedish newspaper these stockholm
newspaper the day after the award
ceremonies III did she thought well gosh
II wasn't is the crown prince is lucky
that pinkie and I got her on the front
page and then that somebody pointed out
that maybe it was the other way around
so so so in the future who knows when
the future is the Nobel Prize will be
given out by the now crown princess who
will become the queen of Sweden and so
I'll stop there thank you